I've actually brought something this is
I believe you may remember this game
this is uh blacks
it's another Atari game right that you
ported to the gameboy color with a bit
of an addition in this one though
something really cool in this version of
the game right I did and because it was
a port they give us the source code and
I didn't understand C at the time I move
z80 assembly because I was hacking this
right so I was going through and trying
to learn all that stuff at six weeks to
port this game over but I enlisted my
friends and everything else and we
crammed we got this game done and we
actually were ahead of schedule and that
six weeks believe it or not like well we
have almost ROM space we're ahead of
schedule what do we do and we're like
let's put whatever we want in here just
like this would you stir eggs are all
about right so there was different
things there's a snake game the European
version has like this adventure game and
it's like it's almost like it's a little
Selda game and but another one I put in
there cuz I had moved out here with my
my now wife little girlfriend and I had
intended to propose her at some point
here because we've been going out for so
long and so I'm like this would be great
put a proposal in the game yeah and she
loves puzzle games I'm doing a puzzle
game now so let me just put that out
there and she will find this thing and
I'll put the crapper so I did that the
game gets released
I leave the game way out you heard her
to play it she never picks it up it goes
on for like literally I think almost
like years now like oh it was like three
years where I mean while she's like when
is this guy gonna propose yeah and like
and I'm like do I propose normal or very
but I have this thing here that's really
cool back yeah get her to play it ever
so I'm very busy at this point in my
career I'm making a lot of games are
working really hard and so it's like it
kind of got on the side burner until one
day tips and tricks magazine calls and
they're like we're gonna do our 100th
issue we want very special codes I've
never been like put out in the public
and it just my brain just rattles I'm
like oh yeah I have a perfect one God
about this yeah and I've got it and this
would maybe get her to play it if you
put something cool in the magazine I've
- leave that open so they did that and
they call her out by name in the article
and they tell her put this code into the
game so I left that out one night with
magazine in the game everything queued
up and I'm like I can't really be here
because she'll tell me to do it so I
better get out of the house hmm
so I just kind of drove around a little
bit
and she came home checked it out and it
was a proposal it was like I started
marry me in the game she calls up on the
phone like with the yes and I think that
I come on and the rest we kind of was
history after that and then if you got
around a lot of people this is like
before
oh sure you bet it was big and I think
that it started getting around and next
thing I know everybody's like I was now
the wedding guy yeah before Donkey Kong
dad yeah